Trascrizione: Alessandra Moretti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Buonasera a tutti,
è un grande onore questa sera
essere qui con voi
in questo prestigioso palco.
"Spavalderia arrogante e sfrontata;
atteggiamento di sopraffazione
sui più deboli,
con riferimento a violenze
fisiche e psicologiche,
attuate specialmente
in ambienti scolastici o giovanili."
Questa che ho letto è la definizione
che il vocabolario Treccani
riporta alla voce "Bullismo".
Oggi il bullismo,
secondo l'Osservatorio indifesa,
che ha realizzato la più grande indagine
su questo fenomeno in Italia,
afferma che il 61 percento
dei ragazzi e delle ragazze
sotto i 23 anni
è stata, almeno una volta nella vita,
vittima di bullismo.
Adesso, vi starete domandando:
"E te che c'entri, in tutto ciò?"
Tutto iniziò quando avevo sette anni,
quando è successo un evento a scuola
che fece venire fuori la mia indole.
Stavo per mettere piede in classe,
quando sentii un gran
chiasso nei corridoi:
ed essendo molto curioso,
mi affrettai nel vedere
cosa stesse succedendo.
Mi trovai davanti una scena terribile:
un gruppo di ragazzi
stava spintonando un altro ragazzo
e subito dopo gli abbassarono
i pantaloni davanti a tutti.
Nessuno fece nulla: solo ridere
di un ragazzo che stava piangendo.
A quel punto non ce la feci più:
mi feci coraggio,
e aiutai quel ragazzo
ad aggiustarsi i pantaloni;
e subito dopo, andai
a muso duro contro i bulli,
per spiegar loro
che quello che avevano fatto
era completamente sbagliato.
Non so spiegarmi perché,
ma quei ragazzi capirono i loro errori;
e addirittura, nei giorni successivi
arrivammo a salutarci per i corridoi.
Ero piccolo, e non mi ero reso conto
di quello che era riuscito a fare.
Poi, durante il corso
degli altri tre anni delle scuole medie,
ci sono stati tanti altri piccoli eventi,
dove mi sono sempre dimostrato pronto
ad aiutare chi ne avesse bisogno.
Lo facevo in modo spontaneo,
senza rendermi conto dell'importanza
di quel mio naturale gesto.
Arriva la terza media,
quel particolare periodo dell'anno
dedicato all'orientamento
in cui ti aiutano un po' a comprendere
quale scuola superiore incominciare.
Ed è qui che mi sono trovato
davanti a un docente diverso,
un docente che ho notato subito
quanto fosse diverso rispetto agli altri.
Sia perché usava
un linguaggio differente -
sapeva quello che noi ragazzi volevamo;
e perché ci raccontava
di una scuola particolare,
una scuola che metteva al centro
lo studente e non il programma scolastico.
Lui è il professore Daniele Manni:
da sempre - ci ha subito raccontato, detto
che ognuno di noi aveva
un grandissimo potenziale nascosto
e che uno dei maggiori
obiettivi della scuola
era quello di farci conoscere quale fosse.
Farlo crescere, farlo emergere,
in modo tale che potesse rappresentare
l'autostrada della nostra vita.
Mi è subito piaciuto e mi sono buttato,
costringendo l'indomani i miei genitori
a iscrivermi all'Istituto Costa di Lecce.
E, diciamo, quella scelta istintiva
cambiò radicalmente la mia,
seppur giovane, vita.
La prima settimana di scuola,
il prof aveva ragione:
era una scuola diversa,
si era subito dimostrata
una scuola diversa.
Tant'è che già il secondo giorno
mi ritrovai, a 14 anni,
insieme ai compagni di classe,
a dover dar vita a una start up:
ovvero, a un'idea di business,
un'idea innovativa di business,
un applicazione, un prodotto, un servizio
da mettere sul mercato
e tentare di aver successo.
Pazzesco: noi che a 15 anni
dovevamo diventare imprenditori,
e avere successo.
Eravamo in questa fase di ricerca
quando, il 19 gennaio 2016,
il professore entrò in classe
e ci raccontò di uno spiacevole evento
successo il giorno prima a Pordenone,
dove una ragazza di dodici anni,
che quindi frequentava la seconda media,
tentò il suicidio
buttandosi da una finestra
per atti di bullismo avvenuti
dai suoi compagni di classe.
Mi si è raggelato il sangue:
e mi ritornò subito in mente
quell'evento successo alle elementari.
In quel momento,
provai tre grandi emozioni:
una profondissima tristezza,
una smisurata rabbia
e l'irresistibile voglia di fare qualcosa
per far sì che tutte queste cose
non accadessero mai più.
Ed è così che, insieme
ai compagni di classe,
incominciamo a dare vita
a qualcosa di nuovo.
Non un'idea di business,
non un prodotto da mettere sul mercato;
ma un servizio
che tutti i ragazzi
e le ragazze potevano usare
per poter evitare
che succedesse la situazione
della ragazzina di 12 anni di Pordenone.
Quindi, tutti quei ragazzi
che non stavano vivendo
la loro adolescenza
con la giusta e meritata gioia,
serenità e spensieratezza.
Nasce così "Mabasta".
Che non è solo un'esclamazione,
ma è anche un acronimo
di "Movimento Anti Bullismo
Animato da STudenti Adolescenti."
Pochi giorni dopo l'annuncio del progetto,
il Corriere della Sera fece
un grandissimo articolo sul giornale,
con occhiello in prima pagina;
e di lì, a catena,
cominciarono a intervistarci
tutti i tg nazionali, Striscia la notizia.
Nove mesi dopo, nell'autunno del 2016,
il presidente Mattarella ci concesse
la medaglia d'oro della Repubblica;
e un anno dopo, nel 2007,
finimmo anche a Sanremo
con Carlo Conti e Maria De Filippi.
Poi, nel corso degli anni
incontrammo anche Papa Francesco,
Tom Holland, l'autore di Spider Man.
Abbiamo ricevuto numerosi premi,
come per esempio il Best Student start up,
diventando la migliore startup
studentesca europea.
Ma questa è una minima parte,
perché fare tutto questo è bellissimo:
che ragazzi di 15 anni facciano
tutte 'ste cose è molto bello;
però non stai risolvendo il problema.
Quindi decidemmo di incominciare
ad andare nelle scuole,
di incominciare a incontrare
gli studenti, le studentesse
e chiedere a loro
quale fosse questo problema.
E ci colpì subito il fatto
che loro non sapevano cosa fare;
e che molto spesso, per paura,
preferivano rimanere indifferenti.
A quel punto, decidemmo di tentare noi
di dare una soluzione al tutto.
Nascono, così, le sei azioni
chiamate "Modello MaBasta":
azioni che rendono protagonisti
proattivi i giovani stessi,
perché sono loro che devono
metterle in pratica.
E ad oggi, abbiamo raggiunto 1500 classi
e incontrato, circa,
40.000 studenti in tutta Italia.
Brevemente, le sei azioni sono:
prima azione, fare eleggere dai ragazzi,
in ogni classe, il "Maba prof.":
un docente referente per il bullismo
che ha il compito di ascoltare i ragazzi
e prendere i giusti provvedimenti.
Seconda azione: far compilare
a tutti i ragazzi il "Maba test",
un questionario anonimo
che è utile ai ragazzi
per poter raccontare qualsiasi cosa
senza nessun problema,
utile al prof per sondare
la situazione presente in classe,
e quindi capire eventuali problematiche.
E inoltre,
questo questionario è molto utile
perché informa i ragazzi sulle leggi
e su alcune definizioni importanti.
Terza azione, il cuore
del modello "MaBasta":
fare eleggere dai ragazzi i "bulliziotti"
e le "bulliziotte" di classe,
normalissimi studenti
che hanno il compito di intervenire
dove nascessero eventuali casi sospetti;
è un compito molto importante
dato ai ragazzi,
perché loro sono i primi
che possono accorgersi,
ed essere informati
su eventuali atti in classe.
Però, un altro compito molto importante
che hanno questi bulliziotti
è anche quello di aiutare la vittima,
non farla sentire sola,
quindi creare intorno a lei
un gruppo coeso e unito di amici
che allo stesso tempo vadano dal bullo
per fargli comprendere
che sta sbagliando tutto.
Se i bulliziotti
non riescono nel loro intento,
devono andare dagli adulti a raccontargli
tutto quello che è successo,
e farsi dare una mano.
Quarta azione:
installare in ogni scuola una "Bullibox",
un'urna dove chiunque
può imbucare segnalazioni,
anche in modo anonimo,
per segnalare ogni caso
di bullismo e cyberbullismo.
Poi sarà cura del "Mabaprof"
verificare l'esattezza
delle informazioni scritte dai ragazzi,
e prendere i provvedimenti.
Quinta azione: il "MaBa DAD":
Digital Antibullying Desk,
un centro d'ascolto digitale,
attivo sul nostro sito,
dove chiunque può inviare
segnalazioni telematiche, anche anonime,
tramite smartphone, tablet, pc.
Il Centro d'Ascolto Digitale
è sempre attivo sul nostro sito:
ed è nostra cura ricevere
e inoltrare le segnalazioni
al referente per il bullismo,
al dirigente,
o agli esperti come psicologi,
avvocati, la Polizia postale.
Sesta azione: l'obiettivo
del modello MaBasta,
perché [il punto] è l'obiettivo
del modello "MaBasta":
ricevere il titolo
di "classe debullizzata",
ovvero una classe
dove i ragazzi certificano
di non avere nessuna forma
di bullismo, o cyberbullismo.
Durante questi sei anni
di contrasto a questo fenomeno,
ho avuto l'opportunità di comprendere
che forse la parola bullismo
viene poco presa sul serio,
perché in pochi ne conoscono
le vere conseguenze:
una di queste è la morte.
Basta fare un rapido giro su internet,
e cercare ragazzi di dodici,
tredici, quattordici anni,
per avere un'infinità di storie
di ragazzi morti per questa causa.
E sempre nel corso di questi anni,
ho compreso che se il bullismo esiste,
non è solo colpa dei bulli:
se le vittime muoiono,
è anche colpa nostra, di noi spettatori
che la maggior parte delle volte
preferiamo rimanere inermi,
e non fare nulla,
anziché essere uniti per, semplicemente,
anche andare contro il bullo
e dirgli che sta sbagliando,
che non sta bene;
perché nessuno si sognerebbe
di insultare un altro
per il colore della pelle,
per il peso e la statura,
o addirittura per dei
quadretti appesi in camera.
Quindi, se il bullo è tale,
lo è perché molto probabilmente,
quasi sicuramente
avrà una situazione
particolare in famiglia;
la maggior parte di loro
non sa come avere degli amici.
Ecco perché vanno aiutati.
E con questo non voglio giustificare
il comportamento ingiustificabile
che hanno nei confronti dei coetanei;
ma una volta fatta sentire in un gruppo
la vittima, una volta aiutata la vittima,
spiegamo al bullo quello che ha fatto,
perché solo se comprende
che deve essere aiutato
possiamo prevenire altri atti di bullismo.
Proprio per questa mia voglia
di far comprendere a tutti
cos'è questa piaga, questa problematica,
a giugno 2020, subito dopo
essermi diplomato,
ho fatto la mia scelta
di vita e di lavoro;
e oggi, che ho appena 20 anni,
ho già sei anni di esperienza alle spalle
e sono il team leader
del nuovo team di "MaBasta":
un gruppo di 28 ragazzi,
dai 14 ai 17 anni,
che ogni giorno si impegnano
a non far sentire sole le vittime,
a incoraggiare gli spettatori
a non essere tali
e a trovare una soluzione
in ogni modo possibile
per aiutare i bulli e le bulle
a trovare la loro serenità.
Ed è anche per questo che oggi,
da questo prestigioso palco,
vorrei rinnovare il mio appello
a tutti i giovani.
Anzi: vi va di farlo insieme?
Lo facciamo insieme?
Al mio tre lanciamo un urlo,
un urlo che raggiunga ogni angolo
d'Italia e del mondo.
Però dobbiamo farlo, eh?
Dobbiamo farlo, e lo dovete fare.
I ragazzi lo fanno, nelle scuole medie,
quindi voglio massima partecipazione.
Dobbiamo gridare: "Diamoci al sociale! ".
Ok?
Guardate che se non viene bene
ripetiamo, tanto abbiamo tempo.
Uno, due, tre!
"Diamoci al sociale".
Grazie mille per l'attenzione.
(Applausi)